[Musique]
le colonel john glenn a inscrit
aujourd'hui son nom dans la courte liste
du conquérant de l'infini et c'est la
première fois que le monde entier était
convié à assister à ce départ
extraordinaire d'un homme pour le cosmos
dans le blockhaus de commandement le
compte à rebours après s'est interrompu
cinq fois arrive à sa fin 3 2 1
du parti
dans toute l'amérique des pousuites ce
même départ sur les écrans de télévision
la fusée suit sa course on sait que le
projet comportait trois tours de la
terre on sait aussi que pendant les deux
derniers tours par suite de difficultés
survenues dans le système de contrôle
automatique grain dit assuré à la main
les opérations de stabilisation de sa
capsule quatre heures 56 minutes après
son départ
la capsule retombé au point prévu dans
la mer des caraïbes et 18 minutes après
son contact avec l'océan était récupéré
à bord du destroyer nord
elle sortait ayant accompli autour du
globe une randonnée de 50000 km il
n'avait jamais cessé de rester en
communication avec la paix
transporté par hélicoptère à bord du
porte-avions randolph glen il était
l'objet d'une première réception dont la
chaleur laisse augurer l'accueil que lui
réservent une amérique qui oublie
aujourd'hui les déceptions de ses
précédents échecs glenn dans le cosmos
et passe bien des rancoeurs et peut-être
en fait à porte qui l'animent immense
abaissement
[Musique]
il a fallu 50 ans au rugby français pour
en arriver là quelques minutes de jeu
seulement suffisent taux français
maillot français pour commencer
l'admirable leçon qu'il s'apprête à
donner aux anglais et pourtant la chance
n'est pas du côté de la france
cdc il le manque de quelques centimètres
sans doute est ce là reculer pour mieux
sauter la leçon continue rien ne serait
arrêtée là remarquable partie des avants
de l'équipe de france qui jouent comme
des trois quarts jamais on a vu cela sur
un terrain de rugby résultat les 1/4
d'heure de jeu premier essai pour la
france que transforme albaladejo 5 à 0
alors à peine y croire dans les tribunes
et puis en deuxième mi temps ça repart
et là on va assister aux plus belles et
sec et jamais marqué une équipe de rugby
un essai auquel on rêve parfois mais
sans y croire ce rêve devient contente
une réalité à toi à moi encore à toi à
moi
et voilà comment ton art que trois
points
cet essai c'est en quelque sorte un
sommet du rugby un sommet que nous
allons vous faire revivre l'un après
l'autre chaque joueur à toucher la balle
regardez
et quiconque dans les tribunes de
spectateurs fils mais ce n'est pas
terminé
cette spectatrice qui a du flair appui
avec beaucoup de générosité l'ultime
attaque française et c'est le troisième
essai transformé 13 à 0 pour l'équipe de
france qui est quasi certaine de
remporter le tournoi des six nations
non
dans paris comme en algérie la série des
plasticages continue aux champs-elysées
même hier encore simple exemple entre
des dizaines d'autres le figaro était la
victime d'un de ces attentats si ces
manifestations marquent une volonté de
gêner la signature des accords elle
n'influe en rien sur la détermination du
général de gaulle qui a appelé à
l'elysée les principaux chefs des
circonscriptions militaires pour leur
préciser leur mission à la veille d'un
cessez-le-feu
par ailleurs et dans le même climat les
route qui mène au château tournoi
benbella et ses compagnons attendent
l'heure de la libération ont vu passer
de nouvelles forces de police le système
de sécurité vient d'être encore renforcé
et des auto mitrailleuses anti-aériennes
ont même pris place dans les environs du
château
quant aux grandes villes d'algérie alger
ou oran chaque journée il compte deux
nouvelles victimes
coup sur coup une série d'attentats a
ensanglanté le coeur même d'alger de la
place du gouvernement à bab el oued la
police et l'armée ont dû pour empêcher
une extension possible du drame bouclé
le quartier
sur ce dramatique qui annonce peut être
une fin il est possible a dit le général
de gaulle que dans les jours qui
viennent une douloureuse épreuve
s'achève
le retour de glen à cap canaveral de
trois jours plus tôt il était parti pour
le cosmos l'amérique a voulu qu'il soit
triomphale
de l'aérodrome de st patrick à la base
des fusées ce fut pour glen sa femme et
ses enfants une suite ininterrompue
d'acclamations ainsi un peuple le
remercier d'avoir réussi en son nom un
exploit dont on n'oubliera pas de sitôt
les péripéties
il était 9h 50 aux usa à 160 km de la
terre la capsule mercury se séparaient
comme prévu du dernier étage de la fusée
glenn qu'une caméra automatique à filmer
commençait son premier tour de tête de
petites fusées latéral entraient en
action elle provoquer un retournement
qui plaçait la capsule en position de
croisière une opération délicate encore
la stabilisation dans l'angle de vol
obtenu par le moyen de fusées latéral
glenn prenait son premier repas au
dessus de l'afrique purée de boeuf et de
légumes bouillis extrait d'un tube de
matières plastiques
trois fois le cosmonaute faisait ainsi
le tour de la terre il fallait
maintenant entré dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
qui de nouveau une manoeuvre difficile
l'allumage des rétrofusées qui en
ralentissant la course de l'engin avait
permettre d'amorcer sa chute
à 14h40 le parachute été déployés les
amortisseurs libéré et 4 56 minutes
après son départ glenn touche à l'océan
l'extraordinaire aventure était terminée
[Musique]
elle valait à john glenn d'être
accueillis maintenant à cap canaveral
par le président kennedy et devant les
techniciens qui avaient préparé le
voyage celui ci lui remettait la
médaille des services exceptionnels
clem a réussi et la réussite de glen à
effacer les échecs antérieurs l'homme
que l'amérique fait aujourd'hui avec
tant d'enthousiasmé
c'est avant tout celui qui lui a redonné
la confiance
et l'espoir
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors des collections d'été a sonné pour
tout le monde dans les messieurs dans
les salons du crayon ou le groupe des
cinq toujours à l'avant garde de la mode
masculine a lancé son offensive de pâtes
le triomphe du gilet ne coupe pas
l'appétit et l'audace des détails
semblent même d'un défunt en dépit de
l'affinement de la silhouette beaucoup
d'indépendance et beaucoup d'imagination
assez pauvre homme bien perdu leur
effacement vestimentaire d'autrefois
[Musique]
réapparition de la ganse veste ferment
aux pantalons étroits sans revers taille
plus marqué telles sont les
caractéristiques de la saison est le
signe général d'une couleur leblond fort
avec c est qu en doublure ainsi dit
l'axiome les lions de la mop l'est aux
femmes tard dit aussi l'axiome les
femmes aiment les animaux
coup d'état chez dior ou presque alors
qu'on attendait le succès de toutes les
ampleurs d'une taille fine à sa place ou
même remonter voici que mark bohr dans
une collection qui n'a dit on jamais eu
tant de fidèles à ramener la jupe aux
genoux et la taille aux anges la guerre
de la taille est donc déclarée
[Musique]
longueur de la jupe droite la plupart du
temps légèrement diminué ceintures sur
les hanches qui allonge le buste la
ligne dior en contradiction avec toutes
les prévisions créer une féminité
nouvelle et les trois grâces de cette
année sont authentiquement des grâces
nouvelle mode
d'ailleurs avait est désinvolte courte
akol dégager sa compagne de juba
facettes ou de quelques plis c'est la
blouse fait sa rentrée
pour les robes robes d'après-midi robes
de cocktail silhouette droite même dans
l'emploi mais des pertes des ruches et
des volants sonne l'heure des chichis
que des saisons plus dépouillé nous
avait fait oublier
[Applaudissements]
de longs fourreaux créer l'ambiance du
soir c'est un soir de paris d'une
silhouette de paris une saison de paris
avec ses arpèges et ses points d'orgue
pianissimo
fortissimo diorissimo
[Musique]